snack swaps destroys the one thing I
loved I'm showing me that there's
something better it's not my fault hey
that's okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
so Malaysia very diverse we have you
know Chinese Indians and Malays so each
different ethnic group tend to have
their own different snacks families that
know I once had a trip booked to
Malaysia and I didn't end up getting to
go
well now you got a full Malaysian
exposure you got a Malaysian person and
some exactly oh my gosh I know this Matt
yeah can we talk about the baby the
naked baby on the package murugu means
like a fried snack and an econ means
fish this might not taste similar at all
but the same concept I feel like I ate
these a ton when I was a child it's the
healthy snack that smiles back until you
bite their heads off oh okay this
actually doesn't taste that different
from the goldfish he's very dangerous
because can easily get eaten up if I
ever met a person who can only eat one
goldfish they would scare the living
crap out of me give these I would love
to put like in a soup it's cool upside
and Grandma like honey I'm gonna make
you some soup baby and then she put
these right next to my damn suit I just
don't want ace the cheese I just taste
the salt I do have some favorite like
American snacks but this is not one of
them sorry goldfish who wins today she
does and I'm not gonna try to pronounce
it really good I love chili cheese
Fritos like I put it on my burger I put
it on my exes I mean ideas for what you
don't love yourself until you've got a
chili cheese freedom in your mouth what
do you got for me
beaker chicken flavor it's necks I don't
mean though they put it near my nose I
could like just yeah I know oh I can
smell those more than I can smell these
coming yeah you know I feel like you
would really have to like enjoy it by
eating a few oh look at our wedding
together
there you got one two three four I just
like it I mean I would do that when I'm
when I'm
all alone this is like new relationship
[Music]
would you prefer I mean I guess it
depends on my mood if I was drunk I
would eat the hell out of these oh yeah
I actually believe that they both win I
think they taste better together chicken
chili cheese growing up as a kid my mom
will make ramen noodles and I just like
oh this tastes like cheap so instead I
would just eat it just like straight out
the package because it felt more like a
snack instead of a meal
oh so this is called mommy monster yeah
mommy monster and a special thing about
this is that it's specifically marketed
and sold as a noodle snack to eat lunch
dry oh wow great I don't even know
people ate like ramen Drive ramen
yeah really good
how does crunch here yeah a bit more
like intentionally made yeah this is
wrong it's not the same way as Malaysian
ramen you know I mean I mean nobody wins
money no men so I knew we were gonna
have some of these small in size look
packs a punch this is like the kind of
candy you get from your grandma on
grandpa it's not the best candy but here
we are and well ditto
oh those reminds me of like medicine
Cheers
I know what this tastes like that fruit
leather that you get it like Trader
Joe's it tastes just like that sake the
fruit leather I really like and you
really like do you like the taste and
flavor dose I do because I think the
consistency is what do me off I thought
I was gonna be more chocolate weight
free but it was more Freddie wait for
you I just feel like I'm eating medicine
so which one would you choose I am
Betina - I would pick Malaysia's hot
licks it's more unique mm-hm and it's
like it has a special spot for me too
you know
I'm gonna take Smarties only because I
was expecting a different consistency
that hopefully the taste is fired
bubblicious this is like a staple of my
childhood - it's like it only has flavor
for maybe ten seconds but it's good for
blowing big bubbles I used to eat these
like crazy my dad would be like that's
too much gum in your mouth and then you
throw it in the trash I was like five so
I take it out the trash and put it in
the freezer let's try it this kind of
reminds me of bazooka gum wait - hmm
looks like more floral yeah that's it a
bubble blowing test okay whatever bubble
listens meant for bubbles Oh so
bubble quality-wise yeah go with that
yeah if you're trying to get a tattoo
little Asian bubble gum yeah two and one
I like how things are similar it's so
different at the same time I actually
really loved all of the Malaysian ones
that monsters that I'm totally ordering
it on myself what was that call mommy
monster mommy monster was so good I
forgot how much I missed some of this
next I've had from home it was a real
nice kick back to memory lane what was
your favorite of the American ones I was
in a Fritos chili cheese fries chili
cheese Cheetos every time we drunk
me in the club tonight we should go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]